hey there the new guidance opens
eligibility to thousands of frontline
workers some of them are able to make
same-day appointments here at the las
vegas convention center you see right
behind me
this is one of at least five places that
are offering appointments to the new
groups
we're seeing this bring a huge sigh of
relief to a lot of people here in the
valley
the new groups are front line community
support and
supply chain and logistics that covers
agriculture and food processing workers
plus those in the supply chain from
truck drivers to warehouse and grocery
store personnel people
you may encounter every day utilities
and communications workers
also essential transportation such as
airport personnel
along with rideshare drivers and dot and
emergency road crews
and some who got their vaccine today
told us they're just looking forward to
doing some of these simple things in
life
it would be nice to be able to even just
take a couple day trip
someplace which i haven't wanted to do
because i didn't feel it was safe
it won't be so much of uh of like a
lockdown and we can get out there and
maybe
you know go out and join joy a
restaurant or two
the new groups join those already
eligible for the vaccine including
people ages 65 and up
teachers health care workers and first
responders
this is not the only place offering
appointments for the vaccine canyon
springs high school up in north las
vegas even expanded dates through
friday the neighborhood rec center also
north las vegas plus
unlv and cashman center are also
offering appointments to the newly
eligible groups
reporting outside the las vegas
convention center hector mejia
8 news now hector thank you now if you
at home need help with your coronavirus
vaccine appointment you can use the
health district's central call number
you see it on your screen there
1-800-401-0946
you can call from 8 until eight seven
days a week
we have the details available for you at
8newsnow.com